how's it going breath my name is welcome
back to pattern Norma this is the beta
number six I know a lot of you brother
I've been saying like you should play
more paranormal more paralleling I like
they haven't updated it but apparently
he's dead it just made it like a closed
thing like in that box I bet it's gonna
move snake I know you're in that bro all
right but anyway let's go hello
stop my name is Mattel Clark you changed
your voice bra and my house is haunted
alright cool oh no a laugh so I decided
to record it to say the least crazy oh I
I missed that a lot
I don't know if you remember check the
other enter the hunting pattern or my
two paranormal they escaped into the
mansion what all right
press the left-mouse and then through
the hunting here we are again
teleporter why I like this carpet like
Jeremy what'd I tell you about saying to
my computer well I don't care but I get
it so come in the background I hit a
sticking up
I know Jeremy I know I stay there and
guard my computer jack
Jeremy number two what are you doing I
like to look outside
yeah that's pretty beautiful a lot
actually it looks a lot different it
looks more realistic but yeah I'm glad
it's working on it right Jeremy No ah
you pissed me but nothing is going on
really not even the boxes are moving I
can go through the boxes
like what was that what was that someone
gone boxes I knew it I was waiting for
you
there you are snake get moving All Right
see how the ladies
what the hell don't roll your eyes to me
girl done do it that's right that's
right know I wrote your name look at
Karina looks like she's done Christ
bones
Alex thanks bones what well that is
pretty normal I guess
Jeremy it's my mother I don't care all
right it's got a kitchen see everything
is back all right
banana is where I left it orange it's
there - cool
is it raining outside that pen
I want it that is raining I forgot how
do you jump why was that I heard
something
oh well it's my phone
everything seems pretty good yeah I
guess u s-- loaded that it's calling me
at this ungodly hour
I bet it's my drunk mom again oh that
[ __ ] is really all right mom what you
want she's not even talking to me
mom lame bro what ah
we are the table mrs. Chan stop
let's teakettle doing that there's a
darkness everybody shut up shut off
please why not click 'add what did I
tell you about the demonic sacrifices he
always got Jeremy says hey brah y Italia
I hate em I don't know why I keep it
what do you know why do you lie don't
you think I see through your [ __ ] bro I
see through that oh I hate that [ __ ]
kitchen thing what hell where am i oh
god if the Attic the gretchen lady are
you here I want to make out with you mr.
Sherr are you upside down abruptly hello
ha I just want to be friends with
everyone
don't wanna don't if I don't want to
fight don't want to fight don't want to
find da wonderful
alright I gotta go to bed that's a bar
ah [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
how's that TV even standing huh mekka
nose and alright Jeremy I'm gonna sleep
all right
snake whoa stop aah ow damn it I just
want to go into slave stuff [ __ ]
Michael do something well got a nice
bedroom and they mood wolfy hi you there
Alfie
it's a bear they got to sleep man
whatever you say oh fishy I'll kick you
up alright let's go to sleep it's
totally how I sleep press e to change
camera Oh char CH the hell I don't even
have a dog it's a tea kettle again I'm
pressing it's not doing anything
[Music]
break the gun I'm going to sleep with
trigger a new day with you haunting but
my it's not charting because I can't
click okay Jeremy
well I tell it why it's a jar aback
did you have friends over alright Talia
go back to modern database France
god damn it I cut down what my fitting
what is wrong with all of you do you
know how much this cost
Milan your butt didn't have a butt I
hate you you better believe it I'm
stopping the watch a javis I live in for
one night I can't stop the sea kettle
for whatever reason what was that well I
like you have an artistic side of you I
endorse that but burning my photo
pictures not okay Jeremy and your
friends probably passed out on drugs or
something what what the hell Jeremy
Jeremy what are you watching
I don't like this channel brah turn it
up
white isn't there Jeremy here crazy okay
and he's gonna go up [ __ ] I hate em
[Music]
what that's not what I wanted to click
baby come on gonorrhea all over the
place
what something up there what did you do
man
what I'm taking a [ __ ] you know I have
problem with my gonorrhea
Jeremy all right I will end this episode
here [ __ ] intense ride playing anyway
like favors you enjoyed subscribe to
come bro today and I'll see you next
episode of ironic thousand brothers let
me go
and the never decide coffee for me